every spring my mom used to plant boxes
of violets and propagate the geranium
she's been going for years in small
garden on a balcony in Tehran
I remember her telling me when you move
a plan from one place to another you
need to give it some time before it will
grow new leaves
[Music]
my journey started in 2011 when I moved
from Iran to the u.s. to pursue my dream
of studying abroad it was one of the
worst times for Iran's international
reputation there was always something
bad about Iran in the headlines
it seemed that where I grew up was the
biggest research a lot of people some
were surprised that I knew how to die
and that I used to rise up late to work
the Tehran is a city of 10 million
people who live in skyscrapers it's not
the best place to come from these days
is it but it was a proud Iranian tigress
we were an empire once I tried to use
every opportunity to be a representative
of Realtors and culture
I had statements and arguments ready I
was reading the news of the day who's
trying to keep up with everything that
was happening around the world just in
case someone asked me something I knew
enough what he was asked about things
that I never expected
do you have apples in Iran I wasn't sure
if he was asking about fruit or
computers
[Music]
the first few months were a lot to take
in instead of speaking English five
hours a week now it was 15 hours a day
everything was a challenge playing games
that required languages those felt like
we took in my English competency exam
how fast you can decide what you want on
your sandwich from 32 different
ingredients that I listed in front of
you when you barely remember it except
their names in English and you keep
trying to revert your brains English
dictionary to remember what they're
called while they're at these 1,200
people standing in line behind me all
staring with you
I could hear my funny accent I knew I
was making grammatical mistakes my
middle-eastern features stood out in the
blonde crowd writing Farsi in public
after someone called it weird signing
symbols what was going on was it all in
my head
[Music]
I clearly remember my first Thanksgiving
when my friend's dad bought me a box of
baklava the closest thing he could find
to an Iranian pastry in Florida so the
family your taste would make me feel at
home
you must homesick
I keep thinking about my mom's Deranian
and what she told me when you move a
client from one place to another
its roots may get damaged the soil
changes it needs time before the roots
grow strong and then you will see
[Music]
[Music]